revenons à la lutte contre les
changements climatiques il a beaucoup
été question à québec de la conférence
de l'onu sur le climat qui se tiendra
donc à paris à la fin de l'année mais
quels seront les grands enjeux de cette
conférence chantal bonsoir on s'enfile
dans cette conférence en principe ça
devrait être un moment charnière très
important ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment
élaborer un accord contraignant pour
limiter à 2 degrés celsius la hausse des
température moyenne à la surface du
globe si l'année 2005 alors on espère
donc on ne franchira pas ce seuil de 2
degrés parce que les scientifiques nous
ont dit depuis tant qu'ils étudient la
question au delà de deux degrés on aura
des problèmes de sécheresse et
d'inondations avec un impact mais
dimanche sur des populations qui sont
très souvent déjà très vulnérable
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que déjà
on a atteint une hausse de 0,8 degrés
celsius approximative de la température
moyenne à la surface du globe et
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
nous dit qu'on est sur une lancée vers
le haut toujours puisqu'on a eu quatorze
des quinze années les plus chaudes
depuis qu'on mesure c'est température
donc depuis le début du siècle donc
c'est quand même énorme il faut le
savoir et donc pour limiter les hausses
en deçà de 2 degrés la recette on la
connaît elle et elle est connue et c'est
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre il faut
réduire les concentrations de co2 dans
l'atmosphère on a même un chiffre on
connaît le budget mondial de carbone
dont on dispose les données ont été
calculés par les scientifiques du groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat alors ces données
là je peux vous les présenter elles sont
vraiment très tanger très visuel on a un
budget total de 2009 1 gigatonnes de
carbone ou d'équivalent carbone qu'on
peut émettre avant d'atteindre 2 degrés
ça c'est le budget dont on dispose
jusqu'à maintenant on a hâte au trail à
1900 gigatonnes ont déjà été utilisés de
ce budget là ça vous donne une idée ça
veut dire son fait le calcul qu'il en
reste 1000 c'est très très peu surtout
quand on sait qu'à l'heure actuelle on
estime que le secteur de l'énergie aie
mais à peu près 30 giga tonnes par année
donc grosso modo ichn un calcul qui est
très très conservateur ça nous laisse 30
ans les plusieurs vous diront que trente
ans beaucoup trop long et qu'il faut
très rapidement réduire les
concentrations les émissions si on veut
éviter d'atteindre ce fatidique de
degrés donc il faut vraiment agir et
agir très rapidement on reconnaît
d'ailleurs laissé de latin il faut
diminuer d'au moins 50% d'ici 2050 les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et ils
font vraiment atteindre par la suite
très rapidement ce qu'on appelle les
émissions nettes 0 donc la neutralité en
termes de carbone la pente à remonter
est donc immense surtout quand on sait
qu'à la conférence de paris qui aura
lieu à la fin de l'année et au 31 mars y
à peu près 34 états qui avaient soumis
leur cible de réduction paul canada en
ont entendu parler mais c'est vraiment
pas suffisant les seuls qui ont été
proposées pour qu'on atteigne l'objectif
de 2 degrés à 5 ans jacques est un peu
déprimant des pistes de solutions de
mode horn il sait tout le monde le dit
depuis longtemps il faut décarboniser
nos sociétés nos économies ça veut dire
par exemple pour le canada la routine et
choc publiait une étude tout récemment
début 2015 qui disait que dans le cas du
canada pour ce qui est du pétrole et du
gaz qui sont dans le sous sol sont dans
les terres canadiennes il faut laisser
80 % la quantité d'énergie qui est là
dans le sol donc c'est vraiment énorme
en contrepartie ça veut dire qu'il faut
développer d'autres filières comme par
exemple taxer le carbone comme on le
fait en colombie britannique développe
également d'autres filières énergétiques
est allé chercher du financement par
exemple avec le système de plafonnement
et d'échangé des droits d'émission comme
le fait le québec comme le sera bientôt
l'ontario et ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que tout ça doit se déployer très
rapidement très efficacement parce que
le temps presse le temps presse donc
cette conférence de paris au mois de
novembre mois de novembre début décembre
merci beaucoup chantal que ça c'est
intéressant